what do you think so do you think born
again virgins should make the new guys
wait what do you think
is the new guy christian himself um
give me one guy yes one guy now
in honesty if there said that
only um go for someone that's that is
christian so that can that can
sympathize but there's not enough so but
there's not enough christian guys supply
and demand they're not there then you
can't you can't say like change the
church obviously
the scripture doesn't promise every
woman is going to get married or every
man's going to get oh so she should just
be alone forever but that isn't that
unbiblical because then you're not
building families and like creating the
next challenge it's not guaranteed that
everyone should we could be married
right we'll get married right there are
going to be some what we call eunuchs oh
for sure yeah first shot what unix are
um i'm assuming like hoes probably no no
no no no that's what i think are people
who don't get married
so a man or a woman that their focus is
totally to god and there are some people
that god they should just be celibate
forever
that sounds like church nonsense i'm
going to be honest with you this sounds
like like i'm sorry i'm just you're
telling me that like the best option if
a girl is well woman
as well okay okay but if a girl's a
born-again virgin right
okay and she can't find a guy to wait
till she's married yeah you're telling
me her best option is to be alone
forever that's that's more because she's
more because she's looking you you when
you become a christian you're not
looking at this like you're looking at
the next so your main aim is not on this
life really yeah but you don't think it
would be
like i think it'd be more fulfilled to
have like kids
and like because you're not supposed to
be alone like that's not how we were
creating you have to remember this
though kids are not a right they're a
privilege right so you know so you can't
say god i have a right to a kidnapping
you don't right and then you have a
right to judgment right well i'm not
saying well i'm not saying okay what
i'm not saying that everyone has a right
to kids but what i'm saying is i think
what you're saying as a society is
impractical
i think that like there's so many 35
year old single moms there's so many
like
there's so many single single child so
what's happening so i just i don't think
the solution for that that cohort of
people right yeah is going to be to
wait for the christian men that don't
exist
tell them right but like we're talking
about how society is known
we can talk about how like it can be in
the future but like it just doesn't seem
like an optimal solution i think the
optimal solution is a long-term solution
because what needs to happen is is that
there is a saying biblical center has
don't put new wine into old wine skins
have you heard of that same people no so
literally what has happened in biblical
times
they used to have the pit the goat's um
stomach was used as a wine skin that's
where they'll pour the wine uh-huh yeah
so if you put new wine into a new wine
skin it will hold if it's used up again
and you put wine again it will burst up
so what's happened is that we have sown
the seed of chaos since the since the
sexual revolution okay and we're looking
at the fruits of it right now yeah so
what needs to happen now is that we need
to sort the seeds for the next
generation so it could be and this may
sound a little bit unfair
some people have just it's just too late
for certain certain people for the
generation
so if
we're trying to look it's a bit like
what kevin simon this is what i would
agree with kevin samuels when people
call up to him and says but i'm a single
mom how am i going to get married who's
going to marry me and kevin samuels and
this is what i agree with him on is that
tough
decision and unfortunately some people
are in that situation right so i'm just
thinking about a long term solution is
that we need to start do you think
that's gonna happen though
well i've not believe it or not there is
part of me that thinks that something
will happen because you have to remember
that the world has cycles you see yeah
if we're too prudent
and too strict will happen is that a
rebellion will happen and have the
sexual revolution yeah yeah so what's
happening now we're too loose now yeah
everyone wants to go back to a
conservative model do they you see high
schoolers these days no because
they see the rise of feminism and right
they're sick and tired of this they
don't really go back to it correct
things so that's what happened so my
my hope is that because of the chaos
that we're in
it will kind of force us you know i'm
going to go back to a traditional
lifestyle we'll go back to traditional
lifestyle and we'll be too prudent then
there'll be another sexual revolution
within a hundred years time no no
i would hope so but i don't see the
trends going that way because if you
look at if you look at the data it's
like a smaller and smaller percent
percentage of men are having sex with
more and more girls yeah and body counts
are going up up up yeah i i would hope
that happens i don't see it i was gonna
say i think it might do because i think
people will become disillusioned i think
right now as the internet's opening up
yeah i've seen a lot of professional
women who are literally got their stuff
together but they're in their late 30s i
think i have no man i have to freeze my
hands because you know what is here
one one great actual example right that
i've actually from what you just guys
told me about is um a youtuber right
influencer named by the name of taylor
alicia right
so
i used to watch her when i was like
but i still watch her to this day but
like when i was watching she was a bit
younger
so basically she used to date a a
youtuber by the name of tana fox so i
don't know if you've heard about him or
anything like that
so they dated it didn't work counselor
and she and then she went through the
whole i'm born again christian right
she posted a video of her getting
baptized and stuff like that right and
then up until recently and by recently i
mean like literally two days ago
i was scrolling through the tick tock
and instagram and i always get follow
her and stuff and she was like going
through a bit of like one of those
things where it's like i'm pretty sure
every born-again christian went through
a case of like
i'm trying to find not necessarily a
husband but i'm trying to find a person
to be like
my peace essentially right yeah
and in her like her little video she she
goes and talks about it like look i've
i've done this about two years ago i by
two years ago meaning i've been baptized
for two years
it's not been the greatest time but it
hasn't been the worst time because of
you know in my eyes i'm doing better for
the gods
in front of god's eyes but in doing so
i'm not finding the whole man and you
know and stuff like that and what can
you guys suggest and stuff like that
and it's like
it's your life it's your choice but for
me personally look if you're willing to
go down the path of
you doing the whole i'm being
born as a
new thingy there is limitations that you
have to that you have to abide by
because if you are born again christian
you have to obviously there's certain
principles you live by exactly so you
have to go uh all up against allah she
definitely had sex before that like yeah
it's a goddamn right
but it's a case of like oh i now can't
have sex before marriage i now can't do
this i can't now
um find uh just a random person and just
like you know yeah but it's gotta be
yeah but it has to be structured it's
not that you can't have sex you can't
have sex in the right context and the
right context is marriage so she is so
called a born again virgin what needs to
sorry what needs to happen
what needs to happen is that she needs
to go to her
spiritual elders
and say to her look you know i'm this
i'm looking for i want to get married do
you have any recommendations for me what
should happens it's the pastor
the church should have a singles
ministry whereby they're cultivating
that as well matchmaking each other so
they can vet each other for both people
they do but it's just all women that's
the problem
that's what i say but thinking we got to
get like i said this is where that's job
as men we need to get more men in the
church
and make the gospel more manly what the
problem is is that the church doesn't
emphasize jesus's
masculine qualities because i've always
said this jesus is the epiphany alpha
male he actually identifies himself as
alpha yeah in the book of revelations
but and the other problem is like the
like women
are kind of it's like the church is
becoming more feminized like women are
this is the one thing about catholics
they do not let women in leadership yeah
i like it
they do
most